well let me welcome representative
moffett
and representative mirner as uh
substitutes for the day
and i know that i think
the
democrats are down one
but you have no substitute
so that's the way it goes
um
so please uh rise and join me in the
pledge
the flag is over here
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and through
their mentality
one nation under god the individual with
liberty and justice
thank you please be seated
uh comment to the committee
uh
recently we did a uh
took an action that we could we
that was not legal to take that was the
uh
the bill that we
last built that we decided was going to
be an um
interim study bill
and had an amendment on it so we voted
it
interim study as amended
i got a conversation with the
with the clerk
it's not legal to do that so what he did
is he just stripped off the amendment
so
where it goes
live and learn
all right uh today we're going to uh mr
chair what number can you tell us the
bill number please if you
the first bill we're going to take up
today
is senate bill 329.
let me ask uh
representative tripp do you have a
motion
i move uh
inexpedient to legislate
i'm gonna take that back
sorry uh
this is i move house bill through i mean
senate bill 329 ought to pass
thank you uh is there a second
okay representative power seconds
uh would you like to talk to your motion
or
you don't have to but
but this this uh this bill establishes a
commission
to study uh
barriers to housing development in in
new hampshire including workforce and
middle income housing
i think this is something that
is warranted because uh we've been going
through this uh
uh workforce housing and an affordable
housing for several years and uh if they
can if the study
uh
if the commission could sh she'll yield
some light on what we're doing wrong and
not uh uh providing the adequate housing
for for the state of new hampshire i
think it'd be a great uh
step forward thank you so this is a
a bill to establish
a
study committee
to look into these things that
representative tripp just talked about
representative piamonte do you have a an
amendment
um i do
um
it is uh amendment two zero two two
one eight two eight
h chair
i have a procedural question yes okay
aren't we supposed to adopt the
environments first before we pass at otp
we haven't heard that we haven't heard
the amendment all the way through yet
no no i understand but uh we we had we
had a motion for otp
so we should we
isn't the other way around i i
understand it can be done either way
okay thank you
okay so we have a motion to amend
uh the bill
is there any discussion on the amendment
or a second right second
representative lacellus is the second
yes representative
i'm uh confused because um
representative tripp when he made the
motion for ought to pass he spoke about
the need to study
our housing crisis specific as it is to
work force housing and yet i look at
this amendment and it has to do with the
municipal budget law so i consider this
non-germane to the bill
perhaps representative piemonte can
explain why he considers this germain
to me it has nothing to do with housing
i'll take that the the
the motion is germane because we've
already uh discussed this on the house
floor
and that brings it into the germain
category
it's this is passed on the house floor
yes
um then another question i have how
would this impact the committee because
i also have an amendment that follows
our discussion at the public hearing
that's up to you chairman
yeah okay
well i hope my amendment can be
introduced
any other discussion yes representative
majipudi
thank you mr chair
i'm a little confused
uh in terms of the procedure and
to follow up with my colleague who
mentioned about the non-domain part of
it
this whole amendment replaces
not the study but replaces it with the
municipal budget
so
uh
i'm having a hard time reconciling the
fact that this yeah
you're having trouble with it being
germaine uh not so much the jo it yes
jermaine and also
what uh representative trump
talked about the ought to pass is the
to study the housing crisis and barriers
and this the amendment turns the bill on
its head and talks about the municipal
budget so
how does this relate to the underlying
budget is my question
yeah
that was
combined
as
oh sorry
that was combined as as one amendment
i attached the uh bill which was um
i think 13
um
1393 was it let's see
yes the um
i attached
1393 to an amendment that
this amendment which is 1828h
there were some other changes
in on the
amendment
when i added uh on line eight section
four
i added after middle income housing i
had manufacturing housing
and 3d printed houses i don't know if
anybody's familiar with those
but they're
a
we're looking for ways to to
create housing in new hampshire okay
and
these two were not included in the
original
uh bill
or the
bills pertaining to these uh the subject
of housing beforehand
and
it's
it makes housing very affordable um
and you can go on to youtube if you want
to look it up it tells exactly how the
3d housing works
um and the manufactured housing wasn't
mentioned on there because they built
these in the
in the uh
factory or whatever it is and they'll
come to the
site where they're going to put them
together they put them together and the
houses go up and they're very affordable
so i thought that was important
also
representative davis
thank you mr chair um
maybe i'm just dumb
or it's early but it looks to me as
though this amendment replaces the bill
no
the language says replacing it with you
want to apply that no
it doesn't it
because i was very specific with ols
with this
um
the actually the bill 1393
it's like the you know we get bills from
the senate sometimes with
things added on
and this particular one
was put on
i just wanted to give it a little extra
some help in
handling the bill so where is the bill
that it's that it's amending it appears
that it is replacing the bill no because
this amendment
will be added to 329
when we if when we bring up the other
past motion
i guess i wish
it said that
because it's not clear to me that that's
the case
from this amendment will we just is it
more clear now
representative tripp
i believe if you go to line 11 of the
amendment you'll see that it says to
mend the bill by replacing all after
section 2.
section 2 of the bill is repeal
674 colon 61a
blah blah blah
so after
after section two it just effectively
replaces section three
okay representative manager foodie
thank you mr chair
following up with my colleague on the
other side
um
representative stavis
if i'm looking at the underlying bill
and
the second section
is the core of the bill the members of
the commission shall
be as follows and this amendment
replaces that
and so there's no commission
if the underlying bill
is replaced so
basically then the bill becomes the
municipal budget law bill
so i am still not able to understand
other than just a commission established
and next
second section is members of the
commission and that's it being replaced
by municipal budget law so
how is this the same bill in it
addressing the housing
that's
the
question that has not been answered
right uh representative power
thank you mr chair it appears to me that
this amendment 1828 does two things the
first thing that it does is it um
goes into section one of the underlying
bill and under roman numeral four it
replaces that section with the um
it replaces the entirety of roman
numeral for under section one
and it keeps what is in the underlying
bill and it's simply adding the um
studying middle income housing
manufactured housing in the 3d so that's
the first thing it does and then the
second thing that this amendment does is
after section two which is on page two
of the
original bill
it's adding a section three
so um line six of the amendment may
appear to be worded um
not clearly but i believe that my
explanation should clarify what this
amendment does
thank you further discussion yes
representative mentioned
so by creating this christmas by
creating this christmas tree bill since
we'll have housing and a tax cap which
we which
i am going to oppose
um what we have done is we have
eliminated
the people i i appreciate
i appreciate the explanation and and
don't accept it
um what we have done is we have
eliminated the clarity for who is going
to be on the commission to study
barriers to housing
um that's the way i read this bill as we
try to fit it in there and if we had a
public hearing on this which we haven't
on this section in this bill we might
have been able to understand it a little
bit better but we're trying to digest
this right now so i will be recommending
that
that we vote no on this amendment and no
on the bill
thank you
further discussion yes representative
and i have to say i'm i'm very
disappointed because at the public
hearing uh senator perkins cuoco brought
forth some changes that she wanted to
the bill she wanted to add somebody from
the
uh office of planning and development
and then we during the our discussion
during the public hearing
we brought up the fact that it would be
important that the representative from
the house was a member of this committee
because we are more well-versed in
issues regarding housing and then also
that we would
add somebody from a local planning board
because most of the impediments to
workforce housing are decisions that are
made at that local level
and those to me are very important
components to add to this commission to
really address the problem that's that
the bill is trying to address
with this amendment it takes all of that
away and i think it's a slap in the face
to everybody that came to the public
hearing that has a sincere interest in
addressing public housing workforce
housing
and um
just kind of
trashing the bill to get in this
municipal budget law
to me is is very disingenuous and i
think it undermines the integrity that
this committee should exhibit thank you
any further discussion
yes representatives davis
representative piemonte mentioned
manufactured housing and
3d 3d housing
can you point out to me where that is in
your amendment yes
on
section four
commission shall study barriers to
housing development in new hampshire
line nine line nine including workforce
housing workforce and middle income
housing
manufactured housing and 3d printed
housings
and follow up mr chair but and thank you
i missed that
um and and i actually agree with that i
think that's a good idea
but
i'm still puzzled and maybe i'm just
being really dense this morning
what's the where's the commission
the commission is still in effect
that's why to me that was very important
because
those two items
were not brought up before
in any of the housing bills
okay
and um i thought that i felt that that
was uh
an important issue to
bring up because you know
we're talking about housing that's
uh now the big thing is people can't get
housing it's too pricey not affordable
there's
that and there's some other ways that
that uh
you know can
have affordable housing for
um i i'll give you an example here in
sandow we have a uh
over 55 housing and
the houses that they put up was very
minimal
they had a slab they had a two i think
it was a two bedroom one car garage or a
two-car garage
and they were put together
in a a very nice way
that people felt comfortable
um that was another issue of topic that
was not
brought up during
any other the commissions before that so
that type of housing that's called
affordable housing in my chart in my
estimation
it also has a uh
a ring where
you know
builders or developers could put these
houses up
along with the 3d and the manufactured
housing for reasonable costs i mean very
reasonable costs and
uh i i was talking with one of the
building inspectors that
has a uh
knowledge of this
and
from what they can gather you know
you're talking maybe 200 000 or
something like that and you get a house
with a land on it that type with that
type of thing if you use 3d
housing it's it'll be less expensive
than that
so
that's something that they need to look
into i think that's why i did that
representative davis
i'm gilman i'm sorry
thank you mr chair uh just to clarify i
think uh
representative power did go through this
um the amendment which we just saw today
um
really be begins on what was the
original bill uh number two at line one
number two
uh changes adds all of the information
about the budget caps
and then changes the
effective date
i have to say that i am disappointed
that these two items have gone these two
subjects have gone together
um
it was unexpected and
um i will be voting against the
amendment and then against the motion to
approve it
representative
thank you chairman uh
two things one of which is the
commission is still there i think the
confusion is happening because um
line eight and nine of representative
pia monty's amendment
lines eight and nine replace
uh or make a change to line 22 and 23
so all of this upper section con you
know containing all the information
about who's going to serve on the
commission is all still there however
i would agree that i'm extremely unhappy
with this edition of the tax cap uh
language to this bill i don't think it's
germaine
i think it's a bad plan to glom it onto
here i think we all are in agreement
um
about the necessity to do something with
housing
and
i just i'm really unhappy that we have
glommed these two things together and no
i cannot vote for this amendment
representative gallagher
so the
one further
so um one further question about the
uh german-ness
um of the amendment in question um
the determination
um
the the determination you
stated um
as to why this bill
or why this amendment
counts as germain is that um
is that something that uh the speaker
and the clerk um could confirm for us
the the the
question about whether a
bill is germaine is
that eventually goes to the speaker and
the clerk if it hasn't already in this
particular case the way it was explained
to me because i had the same question
uh as i previewed what we were going to
be attacking today from a
document standpoint and i asked the same
question and and the answer is
that since
this was discussed
on the floor
in uh in this session recently that it
is automatically germane
mr chair yes i have a question
this
bill has not come to the house floor it
was discussed at the summit so this is
the senate bill
that has come to the house so it was not
discussed it hasn't gone to the house
floor so i'm kind of confused with your
statement about
that has come to the house floor
uh
my understanding is thank you
representative majipudi that house bill
is where this was originally discussed
as it went when it was a house bill
and the the senate bill that we have in
front of us is uh
is a child of that house bill
thank you mr chair um with regard to
section three of the amendment
the the language in section three did
come before this committee and there was
a hearing passed out of committee ought
to pass went to the house floor and
passed the house
so
therefore my understanding is
due to those two provisions that this is
germaine
thank you representative gallagher
so
it seems to me if this amendment was
discussed as an amendment to house bill
1393 previously
this would make it
germane
to
house bill 1393 if we were discussing
that again
but were
um we're discussing senate bill 329
instead and as far as i'm sorry as far
as i'm i can see in the bill in senate
bill 329 it doesn't say
anywhere in it this is
a child of
uh last session's house bill 1393 so i'm
sorry
i i don't see how you can um
how you can connect the two of those
when it doesn't explicitly say so itself
in the bill
representative piemonte has a correction
yeah i'm sorry i quoted the wrong bill
it's uh
1194.
1194 is the bill
uh
representative gallagher thank you for
your comment uh i can only think i can
tell you is that it was unsure to me
also
uh and it was it was confirmed by her by
the leadership and by the by the clerk
that it was indeed germaine
yes representative wrong
so if it if it passed this committee and
if it passed the house
why are we adding it on to a senate
housing commission bill
yeah
i just felt it was something else that
had to be looked at and i put it on that
bill
so
representative matt jory
thank you uh thank you mr chair so
when you have a multi-year expenditure
can somebody please explain how the
community reconciles the first only
being able to use the first year payment
of the bond which is typically principal
and not principal and interest and how
they reconcile future budgets
after that
when you have to then include the full
up all-in
of the multi-year payment on the bond
can you please explain that
reconciliation for me thank you
uh only thing i can tell you is that
this was reviewed whether or not it
needed to go to the finance committee
because of those questions like that and
the answer was no
so i know that doesn't answer your
question but that's those are the
circumstances in which we find ourselves
yes go ahead so thank you i appreciate
that the question wasn't so much on
on whether or not this should be a
second a second committee bill but how a
community has to reconcile that under
uh roman 3 sub a for warrant articles
proposing bonds notes or all the
multi-year expenditures only the first
year estimated cost
shall be used in counting appropriations
for the tax cap under paragraphs 1
a so i'm just concerned as a member of
the select board
and a former representative to the
budget committee how you reconcile those
different appropriations that have to go
into the budgeting
and if somebody had an answer to that
thank you
i'm sorry i don't have a a detailed
answer for you all i can say is that if
this bill is passed it carries that
language with it whether it's confusing
or not so it might depend on how you
want to vote on the bill
on the on the amendment rather yes
representative matchupooli thank you mr
chair thank you for uh
letting me ask this question again
uh you know it's a total
confusion in my mind at this time one on
one level
having served on a school
school board in a city
and you know the budget
how you reconcile the first to the
second zero by the base budget kind of
thing
it muddies the water
for all
municipalities
so
instead of giving the
a little more clarity in how to deal
with this
we are making it even more muddy
so
i mean i have a very hard time
understanding it myself so
i wouldn't
be able to support this because
the bill underlying bill was very
focused study
on the housing issue
this muddies the water
thank you mr chin thank you
representative piante
yes thank you mr chair um and thank you
for the question
um
we've all experienced these bills that i
mean we've got them from the senate
they're
they're omnibus
representative man jerry's mentioned
christmas tree bill but
you can attach any bill to any
anything like this as long as it's your
main
and i did that because i wanted to have
another take have to take another look
at it
plus
uh
in in the additions i made to the
commission
i thought it would be an effective way
to go
so we've all we've all come across these
things before and this is nothing new
um
it's just uh i've decided to do it here
thank you my understanding if i may is
that
in in the uh
execution of the town
election and quite often that means the
annual meeting
or smaller towns
uh or sp sp2 for larger towns
uh
that
is there is a feeling among several
legislators that not enough attention is
being paid to the gov the government
expenditures at that local level
and one of the things my understanding
is that this bill is trying to do is to
drive attention
uh more attention to examining is
exactly what you're voting for at the
local level and to consider that as a
representative
thank you mr chairman and um truthfully
i wasn't going to speak because
um it it feels like this is a done deal
and and um i i
it felt like it would be futile but i i
have to say
that um the original bill the underlying
bill
um i i think
is a giant step forward and
representative pimantes lines eight
through nine changing section four i
think is brilliant and and um i
appreciated him putting that forward
like many of my colleagues here and i'm
just kind of doing a me too here and i
don't mean it to be that way
but my concern of adding this takes a
bill that i could have
voted for and i thought would do a
really good thing to put on something
that's already passed both
1194 and 1393 which deal with the school
budget and the and so on um and when i
look at the um 1194 that did pass the
house 183 to 146 it's basically verbatim
while i do appreciate
what representative piemonte said it's
always good to take another look at it
and to make sure that we are doing the
right things this bill is already this
particular bill has already passed i
think perhaps maybe next year
it would be good to put a commission
that was very specific to this rather
than trying to attach this i don't
personally have problems with omnibus
bills if they're if they're good or
christmas tree bills whatever anybody
wants to call them so i'm not i'm not
complaining on that the tag along type
of thing the issue i have is that we
have a good bill which is very helpful
to the housing market i think adding
this is going to take away um some of
the votes personally i voted against the
um 1194 on the house floor
so for me to
accept this within this bill that
something that's already passed
um
i don't i i never look at anybody's
motive for doing anything and please
don't think that i'm doing that
my question
and i'm not even gonna ask the why i'm
just gonna make the comment of that i
think it's unnecessary on a good bill to
add something like this that creates
controversy and i'll leave it at that so
thank you very much for hearing me let
me also add that
i didn't know that much about
3d printing
at the construction level and for those
of you who are
not familiar with it i would encourage
you to
to go online and look at
either
some of the commercial
uh applications out there that allow you
to ser to use a search engine to find
out about three 3d printing that that's
actually houses being printed in
concrete
by a 3d machine and it's it's really
fascinating and
one of our thoughts
is that
this may be a way
to uh accelerate
housing
in a less expensive way
uh and that
we also understand this will probably
take some special uh consideration by
local planning boards and and so forth
as this will be very different
uh so uh
i was very encouraged when i read it i
said where did this 3d printing come
from and and uh we researched it and
it's it's very uh
interesting and i think it could it
could put a dent in our in our
affordable housing
yes
i'm actually representative vann i'm
sorry that's okay still representative
van uh
this whole three i mean fine put 3d
printing on here but i just want to
assure people 3d printing is not going
to save anything when you when you look
at how fast a team of three block masons
can lay and it prints uh it prints a
concrete shell is what it does it prints
a concrete shell you still have to
wire it plum it finish the inside put a
roof on it
insulate from the inside
in and it a team of two block masons can
build that same shell in four days
it's i you know
i'm happy for people to look into 3d
printing but i just want to say that
my understanding and this is what i do
day in and day out
is that 3d printing of housing is not
going to save any of us
anyway and i still can't vote for this
bill
yes representative gallagher
um so yeah i think
3d printing is interesting and possibly
worth studying but the thing is
the amendment doesn't just do that part
it also has the tax cap part so
um or what i'm wondering
um
perhaps since the clerk is here now he
can't answer this but um
so um under robert's rules there's um a
thing called a motion to divide the
question i'm wondering if the same thing
exists under mason's manual or you got
the right guy in the room right now to
answer that question but we'll let him
finish his discussion too okay
all right um yeah we can
continue or um
uh let representative manju puti has her
hands up so she can ask something while
we're waiting
thank you mr thank you uh
representative gallagher for yielding to
me um this question is for the
representative who has brought in
the amendment
and um
representative piermante maybe you can
explain and i see your intention of
expanding the scope of the commission
which is the right thing to add more
options for housing which is fine
but we already have this bill that
passed the house
for municipal budget law
would you reconsider
so that we don't lose the
good bill don't throw the baby with the
uh
work so would you reconsider
taking this which is already past the
house
your part of your amendment or divide it
thank you
um the reason i put it in there was to
give it another
a look at another opportunity
um
you know and and i let let it uh go with
the bill i'm keeping it the way it is
um i guess i'm here so um
mr maturi
they were all before me thank thank you
but
mr samps
i'd just like to go on the record to say
that i'm not in favor of 3d printing
babies
representative
i i'd just like thank you uh mr chair
i'd just like to point out that um we
had a bill in here
about taking a second bite of the apple
having multiple people on multiple
boards who get a second bite of the
apple so i i object to this bill on the
grounds that people don't like having a
second bite of the apple and i just
wanted to raise that point thank you
okay
thank you mr chair um i know with that
we've talked about house bill 1194 which
passed at the on the house floor but
this bill has already had a hearing in
the senate and we have not had any
public hearing on this uh amendment to
the senate bill
uh
i'm sorry house bill 1194 had uh is
still on the senate floor
so
i guess my question is
never mind
representative status
so as not to keep anyone in the dark i
did contact the clerk
to ask him about the non-germaness or
not of this amendment
uh it was stated here earlier by the
chair that the clerk had seen and
approved the amendment in fact the clerk
had never seen this amendment
and so he is now speaking with the chair
about that
so i'd like to be on record as saying
that was not true what was said earlier
maybe he misspoke on that but
that was not that was not true
yeah okay
you need to dress at the top
okay
excuse me for a minute i'm going to uh
confer with the
uh with my
you
thank you sorry about the delay uh
we got into a lengthy discussion with
the uh
collector of the court about germain
versus non-germaine it's a rather
complex
subject
but uh i believe we're we're okay now
where we are with the with the bill
uh was there a
representative gallagher do you have do
you have an unanswered question you
wanted to continue
yeah or i was wondering if i could asked
it of the clerk
well i spoke to the clerk and
the rules we have for the house
supersede uh mason's rule so if that's
your
your question which one takes precedence
it's the house rule
okay so um is there such a thing as a
motion to divide the question or not
then
a motion
divide the question
well we're we're not entertaining any
more motions right now we're looking at
the amendment to the bill
so that that's what's that's what's
before us we can't add another motion
to what's before us
yeah
yes
as i recall representative tripp made a
motion ought to pass on the bill
and then we had a motion to pass the
amendment are we now considering two
motions at the same time
we're going to take up the motion the
amendment first
but and then we'll come back to the to
the other motion to see if we want to do
that as amended
and that and that's perfectly fine to do
it that way only because the clerk is
here it's perfectly fine to have two
motions on the table at the same time
without disposing of the first amendment
which was ought to pass on the bill
without amendment
can i get clarity on that uh may i get
clarion
uh i'm gonna say that uh
uh it's it's done both ways with the
amendments brought in first
or the amendment's brought in second
uh but they're essentially together
and
that's where we are we have a we have a
motion
to okay to proceed and a
uh additional motion to pass an
amendment
thank you mr chair
so perhaps representative tripp may have
misspoke but my understanding is that
we're dealing with the ought to pass
motion on the amendment
if there if if there's if there's some
confusion then perhaps representative
tripp needs to withdraw
his original motion on the bill ought to
pass
i call the question
on the ought to pass motion on house on
senate bill 329
any other further discussion
okay we're going to take a vote
right now on
on the amendment
you can't you have to do this i'm sorry
on the base bill and then we'll take up
the amendment afterwards
no we're going to i guess we're going to
take the amendment first all right
sure please
mr chairman just to just to be clear uh
you have to have a positive motion for
an amendment to be considered typically
the motion is
representative trip moves ought to pass
and offers amendments such and such that
is the correct motion that is the
correct way to state uh the proposition
before you just to be clear we do not
move questions in committee uh there is
no motion to limit debate uh the the
the purpose of the committee is to
dispose of everything specifically to
representative gallagher's question
about dividing uh the whole purpose of
executive session is to consider
amendments as well so if you decided
that you liked a portion of the
amendment but not another part you would
have a new amendment redrafted
okay thank you
thank you mr clerk thank you
so uh representative tripp
would you like to withdraw your motion
and and make it again make a new motion
uh
more closely aligned with uh with the
clerk's recommendation
uh i would like to withdraw my motion
of uh otp for the the bill and uh
substitute uh
uh
otp uh
of uh senate bill
329 and i'd like to uh
uh offer up
uh
with amendment is that with amendment
uh with amendment uh uh 2022
1828 h
okay is there a second second
okay
mr chair yes
um
thank you for taking my question
so we have the process
in place right now what we're doing
isn't this the time that in if there is
any other amendment
is it not the time to also bring
whether we put this down up or down and
then the other amendments or is it
up to the chair to entertain or not
free speech thank you that's a good
question the
the way we're going to execute this is
the amendment that's on the floor right
now is that is the controlling document
if we in discussion
on this in this executive committee we
can talk about
that hey wait a minute i have an
amendment i want to offer too and it
does this and does that
that that
will allow the committee to consider
that input
but right now you can't make another
motion so we have multiple motions
uh
from multiple amendments at the same
time we'd have to defeat the first
amendment and then offer another
amendment if if that's the direction of
the committee yes representative power
thank you mr chair i have a procedural
question
so um i understand that
with regards to this this bill we have
two
amendments before us we're dealing with
uh representative piamonte's amendment
currently
only one
the only deal at a time
i understand one at a time
um
we can discuss
another amendment yeah part of the
overall discussion but we can't make a
motion i understand that so
representative rung also has an
amendment and my question is
are amendments stackable
no thank you
president
yes i'm going to be voting against the
ought to pass as with this amendment
because we heard discussion at the
public hearing
about
refining the members of the commission
at our last executive session i brought
to you an amendment that reflected that
discussion
specifically having the representative
be a member of this committee
specifically having a member of a local
planning board
and also revising the date because in
the original bill the date was
unrealistic
um
since that and representative piamonte
was aware of that he has that first
amendment
since we went into recess of that uh
executive session
i
um senator uh kwanka's office sent me
her amendment that she had presented at
the public hearing but we didn't have
enough copies and i incorporated her
edition of someone from the
department of
uh
the um
the member of the the state planning and
development
um the drafting attorney
with this second amendment adjusted the
quorum to increase it by one since we
were increasing the commission by one
my amendment today reflects public input
expert input
this committee has had that the bulk of
that
those changes for a week
so now to be an amendment where those
improvements are not incorporated new
things are added and then we have
an attachment that has already been
discussed in committee already been
voted in committee already passed in the
house but we're adding it here so we can
look at it a little more to me is very
disingenuous and i think it hurts the
integrity of this committee and i will
be voting no and it's sad because we
really need to address workforce housing
badly thank you representatives
thank you mr chair
i have always been proud to be a member
of municipal and county government and
today i am not proud to be a member of
this committee
i believe that we have violated our own
procedural rules i believe we have
violated the rules of the house and i
believe we are violating the spirit of
the bill that has been heard by the
public and commented on by the public
i understand that technically because
the budget cap bill passed the house
that makes it germane but no i'm sorry
sir it does not make it germane it is
non-germane
in the philosophical and moral sense of
being non-germane and i would like to
know who on this named commission
in the underlying bill has expertise in
municipal budgeting he's going to take
another bite at this apple
thank you
is there any further discussion
we have a uh
i think it's appropriate at this time we
have representative rungs
uh amendment uh her draft and we have
the one that
is pending uh certainly willing to take
discussion as to which one you want
there is a motion on the floor but uh
we can uh
as per the
the um
the cleric
we can discuss
potentially other other amendments
mr chairman
representing her magic pootie
yeah representative van had her hands up
before me
yeah
thank you i i think that we i have
we are wedged
because although we can take up
amendments in order in which case we
would vote on the amendment on the floor
right now which adds the tax cap
language
then we could take up representative
rungs amendment but that
i mean i'm happy to do that because that
takes the tax cap language out but that
would be the order in which we would do
it
so
the way i see it is
you can either pass the amendment that
has the tax cap language which i think
is a bad bad plan
or
you can vote down that amendment take up
representatives wrongs amendment that
makes changes to the
composition of the commission and move
on with a bill that's about the thing
that it's supposed to be about thank you
yes representative anjaputi thank you mr
chair
just to echo my
colleague
this amendment that's on the floor right
now
changes the underlying bill by adding
something that's already been passed
and
if we really want to do the right thing
and strengthen the bill that we all
agree that needs to be done
and has had the public hearing and has
the input
i think
it would be
the si
best thing or best for the granite
staters who we represent
to
vote this down
and then take up or replace this
amendment with uh representative rung's
amendment which is the
1757 not the first one that was here
before us that's just my two cents
thank you mr t
okay i think i'm ready to take a
oh sorry go ahead
thank you mr chair can you repeat for me
what exactly is the motion
it's ought to pass as amended
that's what he said
i believe what i said
was that i
move
uh senate bill
329 and i'd like to offer an amendment
okay is that making any clear
yes
but that's what the house clerk said the
proper motion would be
represented
but after we approved the amendment we
haven't approved the amendment yet
no we're proving ought to pass the bill
with an amendment and we have not
withdrawn
yes
just for the record i have uh
representative tripp withdrawing his
early emotion about the pass
and a new motion of the adoption of the
amendment moved by representative tripp
and seconded by representative piermonte
is there any further discussion on on
that uh based on what you just heard and
what you heard from the clerk
okay we're going to take a um a vote
so we're going to take a vote now
on uh
on the amendment
mr chair can you please state the
amendment number and that way we're all
on the same page thank you
the clerk will do that for us
okay this is uh senate bill 329
adoption of the amendment the amendment
number is 20 22
182 8 h
1828 h henry
okay so now what we have before us now
is the amendment to approve our
discipline
and then we'll take up
uh
well then we'll we'll see what the the
next thing is some of you who don't like
this amendment
i encourage you to vote against it and
if the amendment is fails then another
motion can be made
for a different amendment
before we take the vote um another
clarification mr chair yes
so
aren't there uh
opportunity to have more than one
amendment at the exact session
uh if we whether these passes or not
if this past this amendment passes
can we still offer another amendment
which would change the
amendment which the second amendment
would
uh
prevail
isn't that a procedure
just clarifying okay
okay so
this
this issue where right now is to adopt
the amendment as proposed
or not
so i need you to vote yes or no on that
and ask the clerk to call the roll
vice chairman pm monty
yes
clerk votes yes
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas yes
representative murder yes representative
melvin yes
representative moffat
yes
representative power
raptors majority no
representative gilman
no
representative stavis no
representative mega pooty no
representative vance
no
representative klee no
representative gallagher
no
representative wrong no
chairman dolan yes
uh
motion passes 10-2-8
yes may i make a motion
uh
no i want to recognize uh representative
tripp
first
promotion
what's your objection you just said in
your explanation
in response to representative manjiputi
that we could make a motion to offer
another amendment and vote on that
amendment you are now going back on what
you just said i said it's the uh
motion failed then
no that's not what you said
that is not what you said
mr chair yes can i clarify my question i
am absolutely sure in how i asked the
question and you did say whether it
prevails or not
we could offer a second amendment on at
the committee level and that could
change the motion of this amendment how
it whether they prevailed or not now you
are not allowing the other member to
offer an amendment that i take a big
objection to mr chair you went back on
your word
i came here to do my due diligence and
not having that
opportunity to do my duty
is
unacceptable i am very frustrated at
this point
and i feel very cheated in terms of not
being able to provide my duty my service
thank you mister well i if if i
led anyone to believe that we could have
two amendments at the same time
on the floor
then i misspoke no we never no we did
not think that mr chair yes no what you
said was we could take up amendments in
order i repeated that back to you and
that was the clarification we take up
one amendment and then we can take up
another amendment if we choose to i
would like to make
a motion
to
put represent to um adopt representative
wrong's
amendment
which we can do because we have disposed
of the first amendment
so the bill now stands amended with
representative piamonte's amendment i
would like to offer representative rungs
amendment which will
uh change the bill again
hey representatives davis
gilman i'm sorry
uh mr chair i am unclear on the process
of
uh representative vann offering to make
a motion and you overriding it by asking
by saying you have a motion from mr
tripp who had not made a motion yet
accept that person
i did
i'm going to take a recess five minutes
and we'll continue at 11
12.
i do think that's the right thing to do
and we're still waiting for diane
okay so
we'll take
you take wrong
okay let's get started again
tell me
uh just this point of clarification when
i recognized
representative mann
i was incumbent upon me
to listen to her amendment
and i didn't do that so
i apologize for that
so representative van you're recognized
thank you mr chair thank you members of
the committee i would like to move
adoption of um amendment 2022-1
to sb 2329
and i'd like to speak to my motion
yes please go ahead uh this amendment
will tidy up the bill and add the make
the changes that were requested by the
original sponsor of the bill
and um improve
the representation on this study
committee
to look at our housing issues which are
desperate um i will be voting in favor
of the amendment and i ask that other
people join me thank you is there
i will second that um
and can i speak to
your second
my second
and i thank you mr chair for clarifying
the your process and your
how do i put it i want to put it in a
right light to
correct your mistake or
acknowledging
and
i was ready to explode before that i was
ready to walk out if my service was not
respected in this chamber
and thank you for bringing some faith in
some
respect i feel better now
and i would you know yes and to follow
the process and not give misinformation
and misguided process that was where i
was very friendly
i made a mistake
and uh i apologize for that and we're
going to go forward at this point now i
have i believe thank you mister dave i
have good direction at this point
thank you mr chair okay so emotions been
made and seconded um
yes you have a comment yes uh just one
comment um
this amendment is very much as the
original bill was just clarifying who
sits on the on the study committee and i
just wanted to let the committee know
that um when we originally heard the
bill there were 38
in support on the electronic submission
and two opposed
and i think that makes a difference
thank you
we're going to take a vote on the most
recent amendment you just heard
so uh i'll ask the clerk to take the
role
okay this is uh the adoption of
amendment 2022
1757 h henry
vice chairman pm monty
no
collect votes no representative tripp
representative guthrie
representative los alas no
representative murder no
representative melvin
no
representative moffat
representative power no
repressive majority
yes
representative gilman yes representative
davis yes represent megapootie
yes
representative vann
representative klee
yes representative gallagher
yes
representative rung
yes chairman dolan no
uh motion fails 10 to 8.
mr chairman yes uh representative
piamonte do you have a motion we can
make a motion
amended on
senate bill 329
second no yes
i'll second that motion thank you
uh
well clerk call the roll please
uh octopass is amended this be 329
2022-182
8h
right sherman monty
yes collect votes yes representative
tripp yes representative guthrie yeah
representative los alas yes
representative murder yes representative
melvin
yes representative moffitt yes
representative power yes
represent majority
no
representative gilman no
representative stavis
represent mega poody no
representative fan
no representative klee no
representative gallagher
no
representative wrong no
chairman dolan
yes
motion passes 10 to 8.
our executive session on uh
sb 329 is now closed
uh let me uh take some privilege here
to the committee to tell you that
i am always trying to do the right thing
sometimes i get it wrong and
when i do that i usually ask for
clarification we had the clerk in here a
little while ago he's our expert
with procedures and this was a
procedural mistake that i made and i
apologize to representative vann
that
i made that mistake hopefully i won't
make it again but
there's no no telling i might
apology accepted mr chairman
yes representatives davis
mr chair do you intend to ask for a
minority report yes i believe would be
proper yes would you like to
like to write the minority report i very
much would
this might be a joint report mr chairman
am i here multiple authors authors all
right
yeah who's gonna be
uh so that is
our next uh
piece of business is to take up senate
bill 334
local
which is uh which establishes a
committee to study property flight
in new hampshire cities and towns
uh representative losalis do you have a
motion to make
yes i'd like to
move
ought to pass on this bill
okay um
most has been made and seconded
is it discussion
or
could you repeat the number for me i
didn't quite catch it
the number of the uh
of the bill
of the uh
bill 334.
senator bill
334 representative uh los ellis do you
intend to offer a motion are you too uh
no you intend to offer a motion for an
amendment
okay
we don't have an amen all right so
is there any uh further discussion
let's take the role
sb 334 out to pass uh vice chairman p
monty
yes correct votes yes representative
tripp yes representative guthrie
representative rosales yes
representative
yes
representative melvin yes representative
moffitt
yes
representative power yes
majority
yes
representative gilman
representatives davis yes
representative
yes
representative vance yes
representative clee yes
representative gallagher
yes representative wrong yes
and chairman dolan yes
motion pastors
uh without objection i'll
attempt to put this on the consent
yes
okay so take a break
all right we're going to take a break
we have one more
document to receive from ols that it's
not here yet so i need to take a break
to get it and then i'll give you a
chance to read through it before we take
any action on it
i will uh
i'm gonna ask that you uh check back in
at
11 40.
and then we'll see where we are
please
but
i don't think
no we just need them
we should have multiples
yes
you
okay we're going to now open the
executive session on senate bill 400. mr
chairman yes
i'd like to make a motion
uh they we adopt amendment 2022-1848-h
second
mr chair
just to clarify
um
are we going to follow a process of
a couple of amendments or just
one amendment and you're going to make
the call on
as of right now i learned my lesson the
last time i i stepped over
representative
van we're going to do one amendment
that's something a mistake you don't
make
twice walk over to representative band
thank you mr chair i'll keep my cool all
right
at least
we have it
okay motion's been made and seconded is
any further discussion yes represented
wrong
thank you mr chair so um just with the
cursory look of the amendment
am i to understand that now we're taking
another housing bill and we're turning
it this one into a school district
budget cap bill
no i don't believe that's the intention
what's the result well um i'm i'm
looking at um in on page
six of the amen of the the amendment
1848 h on line 24
it introduces a new section
municipal budget law school district
budget caps
that titles online 22. so the original
bill had to do with training and
procedures for zoning and planning
boards and relative to financial
investments and incentives for
affordable housing development
so where we are dealing with a crisis in
this state on affordable housing
development
we're now taking that bill and adding
language in
pertaining to school
i'm sorry school district budget cap so
i just want to understand um from the
amendment sponsor why he felt that
sb 400 needed to address school district
budget caps well
i can say that when we
do look at amendments oftentimes
items are added or subtracted and in
this case you found an item that was
added
so uh
yes
thank you uh
i am
really distressed by some of the changes
in this
um amendment particularly
i am
astonished that we are changing the
workforce housing rules so that they
are not required to be available
any place not already served by both
water and sewer systems owned or
operated by a political subdivision
public utility or other public water and
sewer utility so what that means is that
if a developer of workforce housing is
willing to extend water and sewer this
would uh
you know
they would allow the the town to say no
we don't want you to do that
and i think that's a bad plan i'm also
distressed by the fact that we've got
all this language in here about uh
public health officers
and i'm
not at all i understand that we can put
anything in any bill that we want but i
just think this is a bad plan to stick
all this stuff in about
school district tax caps
public health officers and then this
whole business about
telling towns
this whole business about water and
sewer extensions i just think this is a
terrible idea and we should
not support it
yes representatives davis
representative gilman
thank you mr chair i have to echo
representative vance point
and i will say that the original bill
was supported between the electronic
filing emails and
the amounts of paper
210 in support to 30 opposed and i think
we ought to listen to the will of the
people that we are representing i think
the
[Music]
public health officer infra
changes and the
budget cap changes are not what was
intended by this bill and removing the
house
housing champion aspect of the bill to
encourage towns to
do their due diligence in providing
workforce housing is a shame
thank you representative davis
thank you mr chair i'd like to also echo
what my colleagues have just said
and i'd like to add that
we have cropping up here again
a bill that passed on the house floor
limiting municipalities in their powers
to promulgate
uh bylaws and regulations
and limiting them to um
not look out for the well-being of their
citizens that language is struck
from the ability of municipalities to
govern on behalf of their citizens the
only thing they're allowed to do now is
to preserve their property
property mr chair that most citizens in
new hampshire cannot obtain because it
is too damn expensive and why we are
turning these bills that will address
this urgent crisis that so many people
are facing so many businesses are facing
in our state is beyond my comprehension
thank you
yes representative manjuputi thank you
mr chair
if
i echo the sentiments of my colleagues
who spoke before me
and if i look at the original bill it is
a bipartisan
bill with the intent of looking at the
housing
crisis and building
and
housing is just not a dwelling physical
dwelling
it is where it gives shelter to people
who live and work and provide the
economic driving force of our state
we are telling those people we don't
care
all we care about is the physical
building and we have control over it and
i can tell you
my
blood pressure is going up and my blood
sugar is shooting up but
just to show that this is another
christmas tree bill
adding everything to get another second
bite third bite at the apple
health officers
tax school budget tax cap
what are we trying to tell and how do i
even support this
to bring and tell my constituents that i
have voiced their concerns
like my
colleague representative gilman pointed
out i have received so many emails about
how important this is
and
to just negate that
and come sit here because i have the
power to vote and do what i wish to do
this
is very unsettling
i cannot support this amendment
representative manjapudi i'm sorry
representative mitchell
it's okay thank you mr chair um
page six lines 31-32 the annual increase
for inflation shall be there be a fixed
percentage including zero or an
inflation index published by the uh by
the bls it says an inflation index it
doesn't say which inflation index can
somebody please explain which inflation
index is that for the previous year can
you take the probability of the page and
page i'm sorry page 6 lines 31 and 32.
and again and inflation index and means
any
so it you could pick 1932 for an
inflation index you could pick 2021
and it gives a discretion to any
school district to pick the one that
they want to use i as a as a
representative to planning to my budget
committee will be suggesting that they
pick the lowest inflation index that
they can or the highest one rather that
they can find thank you
yes representative power
thank you mr chair to answer the
representative's question that is
absolutely right it is an inflation
index published and it would be up to
the discretion of the
school district in the individuals
putting the the article
on the warrant
so there is complete flexibility in that
representative gilman
thank you mr chair um i have also heard
that there are
objections to the original bill because
of the incentives of the housing
champion
uh
towns
getting an extra
chance at money from the state and i
just wanted to
let people understand about the
certified local government program
which a town has to prove their interest
in preserving history they have to have
a historic or heritage commission
they have to provide examples of their
minutes and and bylaws and
et cetera and so
communities that establish themselves as
a certified local government
have first dibs on some federal money
because we have promised to
uh preserve our towns as much as
possible and i think that this is the
same i think this bill and the housing
champions communities that's the same
kind of incentive to get the get the
work that we need to get more housing
for people who work in our towns i i see
no problem with getting uh to the head
of the line if you do your job if your
town does its job they should go to the
head of the line
thank you representative mercer do you
have a call come to office
see no further
one more question mr chair
sorry
um so we do have another amendment
uh so after this
can we present another amendment
once we uh
complete our business with this first
amendment and you can and would you
recognize mr chair if there is
there's an opportunity to do it
what would that opportunity look like a
failed amendment that only if it's a
failed amendment no that's that's not
the procedure
we have a motion now to
pass an amendment
uh if if there's a if this mo if that
motion fails
that was not the process it was uh for
the last one remember well the only
reason we did that is because i
recognized representative van and i
shouldn't have
and i owed her an opportunity to speak
and present that amendment because i did
that that was a mistake of the chairman
okay so in that case
i would have really appreciated the fact
that you know we don't have an
opportunity to present because you don't
recognize if
if it's a predetermined so do i have to
put a put it in your list to be a
recognized for an amendment is that the
process i'm just trying to understand no
we have an amendment on the floor right
now we need to
dispose of that and then if if the
result is that the amendment fails then
we can make another emotion
and that's not the process i was used to
this is my fifth term
and this is my first time on this
committee i'm just
trying to figure out how do i
make it a motion or i can by the way i
confirm that with the
clerk uh
about an hour ago uh and that was
including the mistake i made with
representative mann of how i could undo
that and i i understand it very clear
now
okay just one more last clarification
in the past you had asked if we had a
motion to make i could jump in and see
it but
if you don't recognize as a chair you
have the prerogative to
recognize the predetermined reps so i
feel like my voice is being qualched so
if there is a way that i could bring an
amendment
i'll i'll know this is the last one for
the day thank you
all right
any more questions yes representatives
thank you mr chair hey let's face it
um the democrats are in the minority the
republicans are in the majority what the
majority wants is what the majority is
going to get and that is the lot of the
minority
that is a fact of life today in this
committee i would just like to say
publicly
that
the majority seems to want to go against
the wishes of the people who elected
them
and that puzzles me
it puzzles me because the wishes of the
people have been clearly expressed
in all of our email accounts and all of
the
electronically recorded
votes of opposition or support to the
various bills that we've been hearing
why we continue to ignore the voices of
the people who sent us here is a mystery
to me that i do not think we can solve
thank you we have uh we're going to take
two more and then we're going to take a
vote so representative
ron first and representative powell
thank you mr chair i want to um
piggyback on what my colleague from
lebanon has said about the wishes of
granite staters we're here not to
represent our party we're here to
represent the people of new hampshire
and i just want to review the people
that came out in support of senate bill
the
new hampshire housing authority
the new hampshire realtors
the housing action of new hampshire
business and industry association we
even had a letter from governor sununu
supporting this bill
for us to think that we know better than
people that are working at the front
lines of this housing crisis i think is
quite arrogant and i would implore
my colleagues from across the aisle to
vote your conscience vote your
constituents
and put your party aside on this issue
which is a preeminent issue facing our
state thank you representative power
thank you mr chair
speaker
thank you mr chair i would like to point
out that the provisions of
senate bill 400 are in fact contained in
this amendment
and it does in fact address affordable
housing development so if
this amendment is not supported then you
are not supporting affordable housing
development in new hampshire
representative lasallus do you have a
motion to make
no tonight
well i'm sorry
uh
mr clerk will you take us through the
through there
sb 400 fn uh the motion is uh
adopt the amendment 2022 1848
h henry
uh vice chairman here monty yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
yeah
representative los alas yes
representative murder yes
representative melvin yes representative
moffett
yes
representative power yes
represent majority no
representative gilman no
representative davis no
representative megapootie
no
representative
no representative klee no
representative gallagher yeah
no
representative ron no
chairman dolan yes
motion passes uh 10 to 8.
mr chairman yes
mr chairman i'd uh like to move
uh sb 400
as amended
ought to pass
second
who's the second
oh representative tripp
okay uh
mr clerk please take the role
sure thank you mr chair um
i'd just like to express uh i'm gonna
pile on because uh i can and you've
given me the opportunity so i thank you
for that but we worked for three hours i
had three hours in the public hearing on
400 had an amendment that seemed to work
through so much of the issues that we
had we came to an understanding that
seems to will help the state of new
hampshire and i feel this bill has been
corrupted in a way that ignores that and
now we're going to have a split vote you
know it's going to be 10 to 8 on this
we're going to have a debate on the
floor not on the merits of the bill but
the way that the bill was then
introduced with its amendment and that
is to hear again what you've heard a
time and time again for my colleagues
not what we are supposed to be doing in
here i know it's proper i know that's
fine but this is not what we are
supposed to be doing thank you mr chair
thank you representative manchuti last
speaker
thank you mr chair for giving me an
opportunity to speak my mind of course
this is appalling to me
this is my fifth term 10 years
and this by far has been the most
choking of partisan
not in the interest best interest of our
granite staters when people are homeless
people working two jobs have no roof
over their head because they can't
afford a home
on one hand i work on trying to provide
a shelter and a home to people who are
homeless not because the choice they
have no options at this time
and then we are trying to make some
headway into providing some relief
and then we make this big impact of
boiling everything over
and losing the whole intent of the bill
this is
to me
very unconscionable i cannot support
okay thank you uh
no that was our last speaker
uh
mr uh clerk would you take a roll
uh uh sb 400 after passes amended
uh vice chairman pmrt yes clerk votes
yes representative chip yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas yes
representative murray
yes
representative melvin yes
representative muffet
muffet yes uh representative power yes
breakfast majority
no
representative gilman no
representatives davis no
representative mega pooty absolutely no
representative vans
nope
representative clee
no
representative gallagher
representative wrong
no chairman dolan
yes
motion passes ten to eight
that close is it mr chair i'm making
motion we adjourn
is there a second i'll second that
um
all in favors
all right
we are adjourned
oh my minority report any
[Music]
volunteers given that
representative van g given the
constraints we have we're looking to get
that minority reporting today
hey john i'm sorry
uh laurel davis uh with the minority
report on the first one whatever that
one did you guys think
329.
yes i did thank you